so if you're a true coffee nerd you know
that today is national latte day and
this morning we're
learning the secret science behind the
perfect latte courtesy of our own
barista
or baristash is live
to tell us how we can score a free drink
today hector good morning to you sir
today and not just today actually also
for the next couple of days but more on
that in just a second
let me show you our beautiful
coffee beans which we just roasted you
saw it live you saw you witnessed this
live on the air as we were roasting the
coffee beans
now we can smell it and we are fully
awake well not really we have like 10
more
coffee mugs to go through so tiffany
styles here at the jolt coffee company
at the lgbtq center is going to
remind me how to steam some milk it's
been about 15 years since i
last gave this a try so we have our milk
here
what kind of milk is this is oat milk
it's delicious
delicious delicious all right so we put
this in here for
yeah you're good and then we're just
going to tilt the pitcher a little bit
and then we're going to crank it open
yeah
keep on cranking it open there do you
hear that right
yeah and then we're gonna lower the
pictures
there we go let it catch some air how
hard is this for those who do it for the
very first time
um it
[Laughter]
the secret is the secret is
to not do this these are way too many
bubbles and they are way too large so
a secret when you're steaming some milk
is you gotta bang it right you gotta hit
it against the counter so
we're gonna give that a try and usually
it gets rid of the
bubbles so here you go so one two
three four good
i think you're great this is like the
best shift ever
all right so we have we make our
espresso here
got to simmer down i had too much
caffeine earlier so we're going to pull
a double shot here
double shot make your maybe yes make it
a plot oh
a quad we could do a quad i'm down for
that
all right we're getting our mug one
second guys we're almost there we're
almost there all right so as we do this
so today on national latte day and until
february 14th right
yes your own coffee beans using this
one-of-a-kind machine
and tell us for everyone at home how
they can score a free
latte you can if you come and join our
roaster experience
online you can get a free latte while
you come and roast with us and we can
talk
coffee um also if you're um
if you purchase a pound of our pride
blend coffee a portion of it goes back
to the lgbtq center but we're also
giving a free latte with that as well
all right so check this out we are
making some beautiful artwork here
pouring it and eventually we will be
making our design
and that's either a leaf a peach
what do you see here it's looking
beautiful but here's another trick
here's another trick i learned you get a
stirring stick
and you get to make some designs look at
this
designs just like that there you go
so what is this now i guess it's up for
interpretation right uh yeah
it's a beautiful flower i see an orchid
now oh gorgeous it's just morse
yes wonderful
all right all right well there you go